Amber Heard speaks out after a leaked
video surfaces of her and Johnny Depp
having an alleged heated discussion the
video obtained by TMZ shows the 53 year
old actor throwing a wine bottle in a
kitchen with no further context for the
outbursts in a statement released to ET
amber explains quote I am NOT
responsible for the release of the video
it was not what I wanted and I am doing
what I can to force the media to take it
off the internet I underestimated the
toll that this difficult few months have
taken on me emotionally and physically
and the efforts made by the media to
intimidate and discredit me it is for
that reason and my desire to make the
healthiest choice for myself and
hopefully for Johnny that I am
attempting to resolve this matter in the
most private way possible et has reached
out to Depp's camp for comment on
Saturday the 30 year old actress arrived
to her long-awaited deposition in LA
with depth lawyers and eyewitness ldt
Hurd who wore dark sunglasses remained
silent as she walked through the front
door of the law office with her
attorneys Saturday morning the former
couple is expected to appear at an
upcoming hearing on August 17th